الطعام الذي يطبخه مهندس المناظر الطبيعية
فيل دان هو أكثر من مجرد وجبة ،
إنه تحد شخصي
يعطي لمحة عن كيفية استهلاك الناس
للطعام
في المدن حول العالم ،
اخترت هذا التحدي لتناول الطعام
الذي نمت في المدينة المستدامة
لمدة 365 يومًا فقط.  لتحقيق هدفه ،
يعتمد دان على مجتمعه المحلي الموجود
في حي في دبي يُدعى
المدينة المستدامة ،
حيث يقوم بزراعة الخضروات الخاصة به في
الحدائق الحضرية بالمقايضة بدلاً من شراء
السلع الحيوية غير المحلية مثل السكر
وزيت الزيتون
مع السكان الآخرين وصيد الأسماك
في  خزان المجتمع ،
كان لديّ طماطم كرزية ،
ثوم ، خس مورق مثل العديد من الخضر التي يمكنني
تناولها حقًا ، وهذا ما
يتكون منه نظامي الغذائي
لأنه يخلق مثالًا صغيرًا
للاقتصاد الدائري للطعام
حيث يتم استهلاك كل شيء
وإعادة تدويره محليًا ،
يمكن لهذا المشروع أن يمهد الطريق للمزيد
المبادرات المستدامة في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، لذا فإن الفكرة الكبيرة التالية
هي حقًا أن نعيش العمل
ونزدهر محليًا ، لذلك نحن  في خمسة أسطح منازل لدينا
أقبية لدينا مناطق ترفيهية
لدينا حدائق عامة
ومن ثم يمكننا إعادة استخدام
حاويات الشحن لإنتاج التوت
والفراولة والطماطم
مع زيادة الوعي
والاستدامة ، تزداد شعبية الاقتصادات الدائرية
في المدن التي
يُتوقع أن تحقق عائدات تصل إلى 4.5 تريليون
دولار في  النمو الاقتصادي على
مستوى العالم بحلول عام 2030 وفقًا لـ Accenture
وفقًا لمفهوم dunn ،
تسعى مدينة دبي المستدامة إلى اتباع التقنيات التي تساعد في تشكيل
مسار دائري
رأينا قفزة نوعية في
الزراعة العمودية الداخلية
لأنني أريد الآن استخدام المساحة عموديًا
على عكس الأفقي
ولهذا السبب  من المناسب جدًا القيام بذلك
في مدينة
يؤمن دان أن العيش محليًا
يمكن تحقيقه ويأمل أن يحذو المزيد من
الناس حذوه وآمل أن يكون هذا
المشروع حافزًا للأفراد
الآخرين للبدء في السيطرة على مكان
زراعة طعامهم ، وهذا
يمثل تحديًا شخصيًا  يمكن أن
يفيد أيضا استدامة
الغذاء والأمن هو فتح
آفاق
جديدة للاقتصاد الدائري في
المدن.